yo sé vallejos jefe en la unidad de
cuidados intensivos del hospital
arzobispo loayza fue el primer médico
inmunizado en perú este país e inició la
vacunación contra el coi 19 con los
fármacos de signos fans que llegaron el
domingo de la noche a las 300.000 dosis
servirán para inocular en esta primera
etapa a 150.000 personas médicos
enfermeras y miembros de la policía de
las fuerzas armadas de otro lado existen
48 % de ciudadanos que se resisten a ser
inmunizados por eso el presidente
francisco sagasti ha señalado que
también recibirá la dosis para dar el
ejemplo a los ciudadanos pero están
movilizando las vacunas hacia 35 puntos
de distribución en diferentes regiones
del país las autoridades han establecido
617 puestos de vacunación el gobierno
peruano ha anunciado que en total
comprará más de 85 millones de dosis de
la vacuna contra kobe 19 de los
laboratorios scinopharm pzifer
astrazéneca y también empleará el
mecanismo como back society